[Music]
Jim I'm just gonna say it I gotta let
you go you for just 5 oz let go for
liability reasons involves an insurance
the one-armed Boston die
I'm on your solo respect Charlotte Motor
Speedway I know how they move the money
[Music]
only God knows ant thing about blowing
up real thankful through jo bang em in
car sir ring and you know we got a plan
to get you now coca-cola 600 is the
biggest race in the year we need a
computer with I know that thing there's
no about computers
okay all the Twitter's I know
welcome to the coca-cola 600 how many
boys the way you the ball twenty yards
I don't 330 is it 20 or is it 30 we are
dealing with science here they're gonna
know what we want on the note my life of
crime is over
[Music]
that is massively stupid it's been
handled
all this in because that looks like hurt
I want everything on Geoghan arm about
its naked - no they
I said no bacon you moment must be a
simple not as people honey they will say
that what you give me my arm please
get this one
[Music]